from your first book writing for the
green light you talk about how so many
screenwriters devour screenwriting books
and they learn structure and format but
they don't learn what to do once they've
finished that screenplay yeah it's it's
that used to drive me nuts I would say
that book specifically I wrote it
because
um it it was the book that like was
never written that I always wish sort of
existed in some capacity uh most of
those books like I think was it Sid
field who wrote he wrote screenplay it
was like that was the one that really
kick-started the whole three-act
structure it was
this amazing book about how to structure
a script and how to like organize ideas
and I know there's some outdated things
in it today but like at the very end of
it there's like five pages that's an
exaggeration but there's like this like
very thin chapter at the end that's just
like oh yeah you know and go get an
agent and do those things and it's like
they'll take care of it I guess that's
the critical thing is
a lot of people write a script uh and
they just sort of expect that that's all
they need to do and um somebody else
will sort of carry it from there and
getting an agent or a manager isn't
necessarily the answer to that problem
agents and managers are great I don't
think you actually need one when you're
starting out that's my personal opinion
that's not like advice but it's it's my
personal opinion is I work with writers
who don't have agents all the time they
manage themselves
um they uh are able to just sort of
present themselves well and use their
own ability to get the door open so to
speak they have a great personal
branding that they've done on their own
online they're extraordinarily
professional they make opportunities
happen for themselves because they go
out there and they cold email they cold
call and they initiate opportunities for
themselves they're willing to Showcase
their work before just demanding that
they get paid up front when we've never
done business before obviously everybody
gets paid for their work but it's it's
sort of um sometimes you have to show
your goods in order to Showcase like I'm
the real deal and I can I can do this so
that's us
you know I I guess overall that's sort
of the the general kind of flow is you
have to be able to um
do it on your own you have to be able to
get your talents presented
on your own
and is that how they reach your door so
to speak is through a cold email
I mean that's one way to do it I mean
it's it's I've I've personally I've
worked with people who are referred I've
worked with people yeah who've shown up
uh
um via email via LinkedIn by any number
of sources who've just reached out to us
uh uh uh sort of directly just saying
like look I've I've written romance
books and I'd like to write movies or
I've written a ton of movies and I'd
like to keep that going and you know
they just sort of yeah approach it that
way it's the answer is It ultimately yes
it's they're just reaching out blindly
they're reaching out blindly but it's
not like they're reaching out with
random projects they're reaching out
with projects that sort of fit our core
expectation what we work with and they
um are just sort of showcasing like look
this is what I do I have these scripts
will you take a look at them can we do
something and we've hired a lot of
writers that way
and they are realistic that like the
first log line they present isn't going
to turn into a green light like it does
sort of have to build a bit in terms of
the relationship
so that's a real old style of thinking
maybe that I need this agent or manager
to walk me through the door yeah look a
lot I mean
again this is my personal opinion so I
mean I'm not a full disclosure like I'm
not giving career advice it's just in a
general sense it's like
um you have to think about what do
agents actually do
agents are actually in the business of
blocking opportunities by putting up
paywall
so they are restricting your access in a
way and trying to get the highest price
possible they're not out there trying to
make sure that every one of their
writers are constantly getting work
they'll sign a group of writers and then
if two out of ten are like hey people
really like their work they're going to
put all their attention on those two out
of ten and they're going to make sure
that those deals are really really
successful in those and they'll let the
others you know if you are generating
look I know a lot of writers who have
written independently and then they go
get an agent their agent I call you know
they get involved and they start hiking
prices to unrealistic levels and then we
just sort of stop working with them
because the price expectations no longer
match the budget where we're working
we're not saying that they're not
talented and that you know you shouldn't
expect reasonable compensation for your
efforts but
you can't go from like here to there in
terms of pricing overnight just because
you sign somebody and they want their 15
or whatever it just doesn't
realistically work that way so those
writers we've actually stopped working
with we've had other writers who've got
an agent and then they got rid of their
agent and they said you know what I'm
just going to do it independently
because I was out there getting my own
deals creating my own opportunities I
was making you know writing five six
seven movies a year at this price point
why should I give this agent you know X
percentage for just basically having
their name on my screenplay when they
did nothing they didn't initiate the
work they didn't initiate the
opportunity they didn't close the deal
so we've had a lot of writers who
actually have stepped away from their
agents and come over and just manage
themselves they just have a website uh
their own social media outlets and they
just sort of initiate the deals on their
own they go to the markets by themselves
Etc
right so similar to actors who say you
know my agent's not getting me any work
and you know but they weren't maybe
doing things behind the scenes to get
work
you know correct yeah look I mean
like it's it's the frustrating reality
of any industry like it's not isolated
to Hollywood it's it's we just know it
it's easier to see here because you know
it's it's it's a creative driven
industry Etc but it's like
uh if you are writing a script and you
want to get your script in front of
people you have to do it yourself
just because you wrote it and it's
sitting there as a PDF on your computer
uh that's not going to get
an offer presented to you by email it's
it's you have to go put it out there and
then the first thing people are going to
do is find every reason in the world why
they shouldn't read your script because
they got 50 scripts to read that week
and they are look if if you don't have
that online presence if you don't have a
personal relationship if you haven't
been referred to them or if you haven't
presented if if you write a blind email
but you present yourself well you
explain why you wrote what you wrote
um that can get attention like the
company I'm working for now
we produce very specific types of films
we do Christmas romance films we do
really cozy female driven romances in
really beautiful gorgeous locations like
very clear-cut kind of movies and so if
somebody's pitching you know some horror
film or some avant-garde
Coming of Age story like we're not going
to look at it it just doesn't fit what
we need we're looking for stuff that's
going to keep our pipeline going but
when people come out and they're like
hey I can write Christmas romances and I
have here's the script and 10 log lines
of Christmas romances
we'll take a look at it and we've
actually bought a few of those
and then you have a few you said women
in Peril so like these Thrillers I saw
one like some kind of cyber stalking or
something yeah yeah we do we do women
apparel Thrillers as well like very
lifetime kind of films
um they're
we don't do as many of those like I
would say probably like 55 60 of our
output right now is like Christmas
romance movies It's a Wonderful bread
and butter sure sure vertical yeah I
love what you said too about just some
people just want to have them on in the
background yeah and I think that's very
true and it it lends to the season like
if you want to feel the season having it
on in the background it the plot doesn't
even matter at times yeah I mean it's
just it's also kind of recycled a bit
too but uh yeah it's it but it's kind of
like that Yuletide log you know when it
was just like an hour video of a
fireplace burning you know and it was
just uh people would put it on the TV
and it had the Crackle Pop sound and the
visual and it felt like the holidays and
yes that's absolutely transferred into
the holiday films it's
I've been doing I've been in the TV
movie world for over 10 years and that's
never changed that the volume of content
has actually gotten bigger